snail mail as we know it may be no more
this week the US Postal Service began a
two-week pilot program with self-driving
truck company too simple the
self-driving trucks will be making five
round trips carrying USPS trailers
between Phoenix and Dallas on some of
the country's busiest highways the
United States Postal Service and US you
know they're interested and you know
what the technology could mean for them
for the future Robert Brown is head of
public affairs and government relations
at too simple so we move mail and boxes
from the distribution center to the
distribution centers for the Postal
Service and then from their distribution
centers it goes out onto your local you
know your mailman or mail woman in a
statement
USPS said they are conducting the
research in an effort to incorporate new
technology enhance safety improve
service and reduce emissions during the
pilot program each truck will have a
safety engineer and driver on board to
ensure safety and record performance
according to the American Trucking
Association this technology could
potentially benefit a growing truck
driver shortage
it's especially acute the truck driver
shortage in recruiting for that
long-haul routes ample across countries
Ripley usually takes around five days
with autonomy we expect it could be a
two days to simple trucks are expected
to operate without onboard human
supervision by 2021 it doesn't get tired
and doesn't text it is a very safe
technology that hopefully will lead to
safer roadways for everyone I always
wonder how a self-driving truck stops
for gas and who fills it up and how it
knows I guess it's the technology but
you know it's called full service but a
lot of problems know the full service
life exactly